foreign
[Music]
guys welcome back to tomes of Terror
once again it's my book review Series so
some of you guys might remember that a
while back it's probably like several
months ago or something like that I
reviewed a novel that came out in 2022
that was called the 666 murders this is
by a British author named Alan goldborn
I think is how you pronounce his last
name I apologize if that's not right
um I enjoyed it quite a bit with some
caveats if you want to go back and watch
that review you'll see what you know so
a couple of the small issues I had with
it um but recently the same author uh
contact me again and offered me a review
copy of his latest novel which is called
The Cult from Beyond
um so I was very happy to accept it now
this book is actually his third
full-length novel I believe uh his first
was called uh family can I I guess I'm
pronouncing that sort of correctly which
she also sent me like a long time ago
and I regret I'm very sorry that I
haven't gone around to reading it yet
like I said I have this huge file so
when I said there's that
um but this book The Cult from Beyond
that he sent me this time is actually a
sequel to the 666 murder 666 murders
sorry can't talk today you know it's one
of those days and it actually has like
uh you know several of the same
characters like but involved in a new
story now I will note that you don't
necessarily have to have read the 666
murders uh to know what's going on in
the cult from Beyond as it's pretty much
you know its own thing like its own
story but I will say that there are kind
of like a lot of callbacks and a lot of
repeat characters from the earlier book
so to get the full experience you might
want to read both of them like read 666
murders first and then read this one so
once again just like last time uh our
main protagonist is a private
investigator named Randolph Landon uh
but this time around his life actually
seems to be in a much better place like
at the beginning of the story so it's
now it's 1970 so it's set in 1970. so
this is four years after the events of
this 666 murders if you remember that
took place in 1966.
um so in this one Randolph and his wife
Thelma have reconnected because remember
in the last book they were kind of like
on the outs or whatever
um their son Matthew is doing very well
and uh they actually have another baby
on the way like Thelma is pregnant now
they've also just moved out of London
and into this like really nice
comfortable new house you know kind of
out in the I don't think it's out in the
sticks but you know what I mean like
outside of London uh besides that
Randolph has actually decided to give up
the pi game for good uh especially off
after all of that crazy Supernatural
satanic that like happened in the
previous book right you can't blame the
guy
um you know he figures the work is too
dangerous and he wants to spend more
time with his family you know especially
now that they have another kid on the
way and just kind of have more of a
normal existence I guess uh so he's
actually even taken a job like fitting
carpet like with a family friend and
finding that he actually enjoys this job
quite a bit like it's kind of like
physical labor and he can see you know
he can see it getting done like I said
it's not dangerous but because you know
this is a novel and it's a pi novel you
just know that this whole Placid State
of Affairs is just not gonna last
and sure enough his old life slowly
starts creeping back to haunt him I
guess is one way so one day he's out
with his family and he notices this
older man looking at him like kind of
intensely and possibly maybe following
him
um and that kind of you know obviously
triggers his Pi Spidey senses
so Randolph after a while is like yeah
this dude is like for sure like
following me so he straight up
approaches the guy it's like like I said
it's an older guy so it's not like he
can beat him up or anything so he asked
what the deal is like why are you
following me
and this old man is actually like really
flustered that he actually came up and
he's like uh the man's name is Norman
Parker and he tells Randolph he's like I
recognize you from all of the media
surrounding you know the case that was
featured in the 666 murders like the
serial the serial killer case so
Norman's like you know I'm sorry I'm
being a creeper and I'm following you
around and stuff but I really need the
services of a private investigator and
you have the reputation of being like
the best in the country and I was kind
of afraid to like approach you but I
recognize you in the street so that's
why I was looking at you my bad
so Randolph even though he feels kind of
bad about it he does tell Norman in no
uncertain terms look I'm retired from
investigative work I have my family now
I really don't want to endanger myself
or them the old man is just so
crestfallen at this news that Randolph
is like well I'll tell you what I can't
do it but I have like a bunch of
recommendations like friends and stuff
that I'll hook you up with and they can
help you out you know and they're just
they're almost as good as me you know
what I mean he doesn't say that but you
know but he's just like I recommend them
so you know what I mean uh so Norman is
kind of like disappointed because he
actually did want ran off to work but
he's like it's okay bro like I totally
understand like you know especially
after all the crazy that happened
last time because everybody knows about
that
um so he's like okay well so he just
kind of accepts like the consolation
prize of like these other pis like phone
numbers however uh you you just know
that that wasn't gonna work out either
so it's like none of the other
investigators that Randolph recommended
are actually available to do the work
like one of them's out of the country
one was on another case bloody black so
the old man is just like so distraught
and pitiful that Randolph actually
starts kind of hemming and hawing about
you know maybe I should he's like I feel
really bad and it's like I really didn't
want to go back and do this again but
maybe I should actually step in and kind
of maybe try to get to the bottom of
Norman's problem so Norman's problem is
his son Oliver who's actually in his 20s
I believe he's like in his late 20s and
has completely disappeared now the
police haven't really been much help
because Oliver is obviously an adult and
can vanish voluntarily if he wants to
that's just how it goes
um but Norman is like look I know my son
um I know that Oliver wouldn't have just
taken off without telling me where he
was going now compounding the whole
misery surrounding this situation is the
fact that Norman's wife obviously also
Oliver's mother
um has recently passed away and so
Norman feels as though
like his kid like Oliver is all he has
left in the world and so he's really
really desperate to find him
so after a while uh after much soul
searching Randolph agrees to look into
the case now he says he refuses payment
and he says look I'm not really
officially taking your case okay I'm
just gonna have a poke around and see if
there's anything that maybe the police
might have missed like regarding
Oliver's disappearance right and pretty
much almost immediately like when he
goes to Norman's house and like has a
look around Oliver's room and stuff he
actually does find a clue that the
authorities overlooked
um on the back of a picture like Oliver
in his room he has like a picture of his
mom like in a frame who's like his mom
is has died right and on the back of it
there's like this really weird symbol
that's been drawn there
now
Randolph because of the last case like
666 murders obviously was kind of like a
satanic like serial killer kind of thing
so he's a little bit gun shy with all
these weird symbols you know what I mean
this doesn't look like a satanic symbol
like overtly but it is pretty weird and
it's a symbol that he hasn't seen before
so he's just like oh like not this
again you know what I mean but he calls
up a professor that he knows to see like
what the meaning of this symbol could
possibly be now at first the professor
can't really identify it because it
doesn't really resemble anything that
he's ever seen before
meanwhile Randolph also has the idea to
visit the cemetery where Norman's wife
is buried just on the off chance that
Oliver has been there to visit the grave
because Norman said that Oliver and his
mom were very close and he was like
devastated when she died and when he
does that when Randolph goes to the
cemetery he actually hits Pay Dirt the
groundskeeper actually says yes I saw
Oliver at the graveyard only a few days
ago and he was with this young woman
with green hair now remember like this
is 1970 so somebody with green hair is
really going to stick out you know what
I mean
um now like I said so luckily for
Randolph a green haired girl it's like I
said in 1970 is very distinctive so he's
able to kind of like ask around at like
local pubs and stuff like that and comes
up with several more people that have
seen them like in the last few days so
you know so far so good it seems uh at
least Oliver apparently is alive and
well and Norman is actually like
relieved that nothing terrible has
happened to him
um but on the other hand if Oliver is
fine why hasn't he contacted his dad to
at least reassure him that he's okay
right because that's not like him you
know so he's thinking well is he maybe
being held against his will or did
Norman do something inadvertently that
maybe like drove his son away or
something like that now the more
Randolph looks into this case the kind
of murkier this whole situation becomes
and it soon becomes clear and this isn't
really a spoiler because the word cult
is right there in the title that Oliver
has somehow become mixed up with this
weird and possibly Sinister sect
which is led by this sort of mysterious
man in a white suit now much like the
666 murders uh the cult from Beyond is
kind of like an old school detective
story with Supernatural elements that
kind of get a lot more pronounced as the
you know story unfolds I guess also like
the prior book uh the location of the
action kind of like moves back and forth
from England to another country uh 666
murders was actually England and France
this one is actually England and Ireland
and there's also something of like a
conspiracy angle going on
um as it turns out that some supposedly
trustworthy authority figures end up not
being what they seem
um and there are also like uh
reappearances of characters as I
mentioned from the previous novel uh
such as the wealthy Hotel Mogul uh
Timothy Andrews he kind of pops in and
out uh and uses his money and
connections to help out in the
investigation because he was like um a
big part of the first book and he so him
and Randolph are like good buddies now
and there was all also like a recurring
character this very upright uh
trustworthy police officer uh DCS
Kendall Quincy and he kind of like
figures pretty largely into the events
like especially like toward the climax
so the cult from Beyond
um actually has more of like a Sci-Fi
slant than the six sixes murder 666
murders did
um you know whereas the the prior book
was more
I kind of think I compared it to movies
like The Believers or the first power or
something like that where it's kind of
like a police procedural or like a Noir
type detective story but with like
satanic elements or like Supernatural
elements that turn out to be real this
one is kind of more like
X-Files meets folk horror kind of vibe
is what how I would describe it kind of
now because of that I think I kind of
enjoyed the 666 murders more because I'm
more into and that's just me because I'm
more into like satanic serial killers
than you know trance and l space or more
of like a Sci-Fi kind of stuff
um but this was still like a solid read
I will say though that um some of the
issues that I had with the previous book
are still kind of evident here
um and I think I brought some of this up
in my last review too I kind of feel
like the tone and dialogue is like very
expositional which I think I mentioned
last time I think there's kind of a
tendency for the author to like uh tell
instead of show you know what I mean if
you know what I'm saying
um because everything is told from the
third person perspective of Randolph
Landon who is the main character and
like the pi so there are like several
scenes where some compelling like
happens to one of the other characters
but we only hear about it second hand
like when that character is telling
Randolph what happens you know what I'm
saying so it might have actually been
cool to have the perspective shift from
character to character like as necessary
so that the events could have been
described as they happened and been more
like action focused and firsthand rather
than just being like long paragraphs of
dialogue of someone telling Randolph
like what happened because it ends up
like where some of the stuff ends up
like it happened off screen you know
what I mean and you're just seeing like
somebody telling somebody else like what
happened
I kind of feel like there was um still a
lot of that and I saw this in the 666
murders too but there was kind of a lot
of that unnecessary in this kind of like
overly jocular uh Small Talk going on
between characters
um it does seem significantly trimmed uh
this go around
um The Cult from Beyond is actually more
than 100 Pages shorter than the 666
murders was um and I think that that's
to the story's benefit uh because it
does seem like it's been edited some
more
um but I still think there were some
sequences that probably could have been
shortened or removed or whatever just
because it didn't seem to like play into
the larger Story one other thing I
noticed a little bit was that there were
also like a couple of events that
happened that seemed like they were
setting up something like ominous but
actually we're just there for kind of
like plot convenience reasons you know
what I mean like one example of that
that kind of stuck out to me like at one
point
Randolph is trying to get hold of
Timothy like his big wealthy friend over
the phone to like ask for some help like
he needs a plane or something like that
I don't remember what it was
um but Timothy doesn't answer the phone
for like a day or two and it seems like
this is being built up into something
having happened to him because I'm like
oh like the cult got him or
something like that but really nothing
happened to him it was just it turned
out that he was just busy and couldn't
answer his phone which you know what I
mean so there was a couple little events
like that and I was like Oh I thought it
was like building up to be but it wasn't
that you know what I'm saying but like I
said I mean these are like pretty minor
nitpicks um overall I like this quite a
bit
um and I was actually interested in the
mythology of the cult which was actually
gone into in great detail so I mean if
you like detective fiction like
especially set like in a more retro like
I said this set in 1970
um and it also has kind of like a
conspiratorial Sci-Fi kind of edge to it
um then you might actually dig this like
I said it's kind of I would the closest
thing I would compare it to is like
X-Files meets folk like Irish folk
horror kind of thing but with but a
detective story you know if that makes
any sense so if that sounds like
something that you would dig then um
please check out the cult from Beyond
the author is a very nice person and has
like uh sent me all of his books and I
think that that's pretty cool I will
eventually get around to uh reviewing
his first novel as well and I feel
really bad that I haven't read it yet
but I will one day I will get to it I
promise like I said I have this huge
like pile but yeah I will get to it uh
but yeah that'll do it for this tones of
Terror hopefully you guys enjoyed it
please like share comment and all of
that other kind of stuff and I will see
you guys again on the next one bye